ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero video sono poi j
oggi siamo su allora lo space quest lo
conosce anche mia nonna hanno fatto
troll fisk west brom cube hanno fatto
troppi questi youtube c'è una roba
stranissima non so bene perché e percome
però l'hanno fatto chi è questo qui
tutti ragazzi non so di che cosa si
tratta di preciso però a prescindere dai
tanto twitter
qui è bellissimo twitter compie anche
facebook abbiamo gioco ragazzi ancora
non ho visto a io sono lui proprio io
sono un po più bello è stato risucchiato
dal computer a si vede perché ha provato
a cercare google su google quindi la
risucchiato il monitor ok
insomma quindi io sono no no no fermi lo
sa lo conosco questo lo conosco perché
me l'avete chiesto tutti di farlo però
non ho mai fatto perché quindi devo
giocare al posto suo va bene fai tu zio
ago ascolta e devi arrivare alla fine
però c'è un jump scher bosco sesta roche
semore zio fester per chi non conoscesse
troll face quest e in quel caso credo
che sia fuori dal mondo è un gioco che
ti prende per il culo se non si fosse
capito quindi dovrei fare un qualche
cosa di diverso a semi sfrutta zio
fester schlick questo cazzo non ci ho
mai pensato
benché un genio ed essere avanti ragazzi
non avrò più problemi negli horror
ve lo dico prossimo livello che grazie
caro mi ha dato l'idea della vita non è
una scena che guardereste pippo per ore
senza un [ __ ] motivo va beh a parte
gli scoiattoli geneticamente modificati
capiamo cosa fare della nostra vita mi
ha aumentato incredibilmente il
quoziente intellettivo da un momento
all'altro ragazzi complimenti a kiko
tizio ha una testa ma vediamo chi è più
genio ok poi ancora lui è poi di nuovo
lui perché se sono magna lo scoiattolo
mi dispiace zio non volevo più la cosa
nuova per nuova beh bravi bravi per chi
non conoscesse il video originale
ragazzi è questo
questo è il più bel trophies questo mai
fatto e sono al secondo livello ragazzi
hanno riproposto le scene dei video di
youtube questa della blendtec questo che
frulla gli iphone cake posso frullare
perfetto geniale ragazzi sono tutti i
video più conosciuti di youtube perché è
fallito e andava così video questo
ragazzi un tipo che frulla le cose e
scusa devo frullare nokia che non si
troverà mai nella vita
ovviamente il nokia uscirà in tantissimo
e l'altro che ci fra l'altro la torinese
che non lo sapevo avrei scommesso tutto
bravo complimenti ragazzi questo è il
test che conferma che il nokia in
distruttive questo non l'ho visto così
devo pagare
ho pagato pagare in pubblico c'è un
video di uno che kakà in pubblico
ragazzi
poi cos'è il quale video di youtube un
cristo si mangia una gomma da masticare
mentre kakà per strada e diventa lei
anche qualche video è qualcuno mi dice
quali miley cyrus è solo per nostri
ragazzi che mi lei che è un po più bella
questa che miley hannah devi usare la
lingua perché sono sei
miley cyrus sorriso da tanta lingua
raccogliamo fondi per aiutare miley
cyrus spaccare i muri facciamo delle
amiche ma ripensandoci va bene anche
così la posta post lei è contenta la fee
poi c'è questo che è vicino a un bisogno
di monier a che video quale vi do va
bene spiegazioni qualcuno ne sa c'è un
cestino che cazzo riediti dovrebbe a me
cosa stato qualcuno conosce i video in
questione no perché non si capisce non
va bè questo ept fi c'è anche vi di
bagheria perfetto dimmi che fa la intro
ti prego non è la intro di più di paese
che solo fare faccio faccio umido
normale ma è così che ha conquistato i
suoi 40 milioni di iscritti
non è esattamente quello che mi e cos'è
un cacciavite ad evitare il clinic
barche ma perché è perfetto
hanno livello fallita giustamente senza
microfono non può fare video ma fai come
fa vj perché se mi smontano al microfono
io ne ho un altro capiamoci cosa
dobbiamo fare ti smonto il microfono
parli machismo lui e basta noi non
facciamo ma perché ci all'orecchio
tappato affossino smontarlo orecchio
esaminati forse forse ho capito non solo
a silos
ma per chi è e sconvolgente sarò mai non
ho mai saputo che dentro tutti di pai
chi fosse una persona ad ora niente ma
salve e che sarai che cosa facciamo
dormiamo vabbè lasciamo perdere ragazzi
voglio sapere questo questo e maurizio
merluzzo cotto e frulla c'è un po di
differenza di muscoli però sono convinto
che sia major merluzzo dai ragazzi
l'importante è saper cucinare e poi non
lo so spero che merluzzo mi dia un
feedback su questa impresa di cucina
anche sto per compiere ha fatto
esattamente quello che ho fatto io
come cazzo ha fatto sapere che avrei
fatto online dopo questa tutti i like a
manetta voglio ma tutti proprio lifelike
l'ho lasciato già prima non ho come di
flight ma disdetto sorello solo clic
armi l'occhio commestibile lo usiamo nel
sì lo usano per il medico mi arrivano i
like a del tutto youtube crasha per i
troppi light my fire questo significa
che la gente è contenta quando nei video
seri ci si mette un tocco di screenshot
e video è piaciuto ma stato lasciato il
commento euro mi piace basta voglio
vedere il tasto sfondato di like this
l'onu grace questi conosco fanno di slow
motion fanno le fasce in slow motion
hanno capito capito devo fare la risata
in quanto sapevo fatto fanno cose in
slow motion
dico questo poi mentre ciò la risata che
che sta andando devo cliccare qua ridere
di nuovo
se ci sono gli sci proprio perché non
fanno queste cose di slogan
ma ve lo posso assicurare ragazzi fanno
esattamente europa al rallenty ragazzi
il problema è che dite che se ci provo a
casa mia madre si incazza d'accordo
ragazzi siamo all'ultimo livello che ci
sono solo 10 purtroppo però un
capolavoro quindi dovrebbero farne di
più perché non mi hanno messo dentro
stia razzisti quelli che l'hanno
riconosciuto meli scrivete qui sotto
perché non ho capito c'è riconoscerete
voi sono io scemo che non conosco tutto
ho capito di che cosa si trattava da
questo bucket challenge questo ragazzi
ce l'ho anch'io
[Musica]
ok freddo perché che registra le gocce
di steve jobs comunque devo c'è
l'immondizia faccia lei sì ma che
challenge con l'immondizia manovra è
vero è la prima cosa che mi è venuto in
mente però è spuntato un contadino a
casa
vabbè aismac challenge amico mio canta
più a zio bellissimo assolutamente
geniali so se c'è stata un file di ice
bach challenge tipo del genere allora
ragazzi a che anche un po soft roll face
questo perché si chiama trophies cube
mi ricordo neanche l'alzheimer ragazzo è
tornato l'alzheimer e vabbè ma mica
datemi un finale decente vuole era
entrato nel computer più che ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio è stato e allora
credo personale anche se un po corto
credo personalmente che sia stato il più
bello episodio di troll face questi
abbia mai fatto è bellissimo peccato che
sia stato così corto però è stato
veramente figo è quindi ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto al corso e
così mi è piaciuta un commento
è un mi piace adesso sì che avete un
buon motivo per mettere mi piace anche a
passioni facebook e con i video trattare
le iscrizioni sono sentiti sia i medici
mediapro prossimo vinto bene ragazzi